in the last video we touch on the three
states of matter that are really most
familiar to our everyday experience the
solid
the liquid
and the gas
and i kind of hint that there is a
fourth state which i don't cover because
it's usually not the domain of an
introductory chemistry course but a
little bit of a discussion ensued on the
message board for that video so i
thought i would at least touch on that
fourth stage and that's the plasma
and i'll do it in a suitably
bright color plasma
and people consider it a ford state
because it has some properties of gases
and in some ways it's it's almost a
subset of gases but
it also has properties of conductivity
that you normally wouldn't associate
with with the gas what it is is
and and you know just so you know
when you fear shares you think oh you
know that's that's a fairly exotic thing
plasma and in the first video i say oh
it only you know something occurs at
high temperatures which isn't exactly
100 right it doesn't have to be at high
temperatures i really should have said
under extenuating circumstances where
you have a very strong electromagnetic
field or or something has to happen to
essentially
bump the the electrons or move the
electrons off of
gases that would have otherwise have
kept their electrons so it's kind of
analogous to what happens in metal when
we talk about metal bonds we we talk
about this notion of a sea of electrons
where let's say if we talked about iron
what happens with
most metals is that they have so many
kind of electrons and they're they're so
willing to give them that the electrons
just kind of float outside of
outside of the
atoms themselves and create this kind of
big c of electrons and then the atoms
themselves become
positively charged ions
because they essentially donated some
electrons to the c so they're attracted
to the c and that's what that's what
makes them malleable and even more
importantly what allows them to conduct
electricity but they're all really
packed closely together and it's a very
dense structure a plasma is a situation
where if you take gases and remember
gases things are pretty far apart so you
take a bunch of gases and they have high
kinetic energy although they don't have
to well they could be under that it
could be very low pressure but they're
moving around and they're bumping into
each other but they're not they're not
close to each other they don't have
fixed they don't have a fixed structure
with each other they're not rubbing
against each other like in the case of a
liquid but what happens in a plasma one
one situation is that you can you apply
such a strong electromagnetic field
that the electrons want to disassociate
so let's say these electrons start
bumping off of the plasma
and so even this you know
a solid has its own shape a plasma will
take the shape of its container like a
gas and sometimes it is described as an
ionized gas and it's described as
ionized because the electrons are bumped
off and when the electrons are bumped
off the otherwise neutral atoms now
become now have positive charges
and what this allows is essentially a
conduction of electricity because now
these electrons are free to move and you
might say oh that sounds like a bizarre
state of matter where does it exist well
probably closest to home it exists on in
lightning
enlightening
and that's worthy of an entire video but
the idea is is that you start having a
huge potential difference between the
clouds
and the ground
and then because you have this huge
voltage difference between the two
you have electrons that are essentially
wanting to
go into the ground right you have
electrons you have a buildup of
electrons up here
you have a buildup of electrons up here
that want to go into the ground
they they can't because air is normally
a a fairly
a fairly bad conductor it's an insulator
but what happens is because there's so
much electro potential here the
electrons that are close in in the
molecules up here
at least this is how i visualize it
their electrons want to escape from
these clouds because these clouds are
starting to get so their electrons start
to want to move away in in the the air
molecules whether you're talking about
you know the air is a mixture of oxygen
and nitrogen and carbon dioxide they
start wanting to get away from the
clouds so they start disassociating and
start forming like
this this ionized air and eventually at
some point this happens to such a degree
that you can actually get conduction
from the cloud to the ground
and that conduction is is when the air
is in a plasma state so it's happening
at a you know the the conduction allows
extremely high temperatures and the
electrons to flow all the way to the
ground the other common example that you
might see something like this or
actually not like this but at least a
plasma state is in stars and that's
because you have extremely strong
electromagnetic fields extremely high
pressure
and that type of an environment once
again and you know this i'm super
oversimplifying it you can get to a
state where the electrons can get
disassociated from things that otherwise
wouldn't want to give up their electrons
so i thought i would touch on that
because it's an interesting subject and
it it exists in in the universe it's
actually if on a universal level because
stars are pretty much all plasma it is
actually the most common state of matter
in the universe although in our everyday
life we probably encounter solids
liquids and gases a lot more now one
other thing i want to maybe clarify from
the last videos i talk about the bonding
between water molecules
and let's say we're talking in the solid
state so if i have
oxygen i have a hydrogen a hydrogen
and then i have some electrons here some
electrons here and let's say there's
another say there's a hydrogen here
and an oxygen
and a hydrogen maybe there's an oxygen
here
but that has a hydrogen i'm just you
know
oh
whoops i don't want to do that
so these are and then this has a
hydrogen and it has two electrons on two
electron pairs so i talked about the
notion and and and we talked about it
many times before that oxygen is so much
more electronegative that it hogs the
electrons and so the oxygen side starts
to have a partial negative charge while
the hydrogen side start to have a
partial positive side because when the
hydrogen essentially all of its
electrons are hanging out close to elec
close to the oxygen it's electron
hydrogen ends up just becoming like this
proton that's floating out there because
we even said it doesn't even have
neutrons in in most cases so it's a
slightly positive charge this will have
a positive charge
and the positive and the the positive
uh polar end of of the of the water
molecule is attracted to the negative
polar end and i called it polar bonds
but i really should have called it
it shows you my memory from high school
chemistry is not ideal i really should
have called it hydrogen bonds
and hydrogen bonds so this is a hydrogen
bond or this is a hydrogen bond it's
usually
it's just a matter of of the name i use
but i just want to clarify that because
that is what's typically used in your
chemistry class i don't want to confuse
you and that is just the bond that
exists
from a a partially positive hydrogen
atom because it's its electrons are
hanging out near the near the oxygen and
they partially negative
oxygen atom in the water molecule
because all of its it's stolen all of
these these electrons from the hydrogen
you draw it like that it's called a
hydrogen bond and hydrogen's hydrogen
bonds tend to form between hydrogen and
well really only a handful of super
electronegative atoms and that's
nitrogen
fluorine
and oxygen and that these are actually
the three most electronegative atoms so
in the nitrogen
nitrogen if you you know nh3
when it bonds with hydrogen
when it bonds with hydrogen it
essentially is so electronegative that
you have the same situation all the
electrons hang out here so you have a
partial negative charge partial positive
on the hydrogen ends same thing with
hydro hydrogen hydro hydrogen fluorine
you get the same
hf you get the same type of hydrogen
bonds and so in this case these guys
would want to be would be attracted to
the nitrogen part of other molecules or
form hydrogen bonds so i just want to
get that out of the way and with that
done i think we can return to some of
the ideas of the last video and actually
do some problems
so in the last video
we saw that
let's take the case with water
let me draw
a good actually let me just state the
problem first so let's say that we have
a
let's say that we have